pour utiliser le flash-ball c'est très
simple j'introduis les délits mission
je tisse
le flash-ball larmes de défense de la
police qui fait bien des dégâts mais qui
se voulait pourtant sans danger
à sa création en 1990 voilà ce que
disait son inventeur pier richer un
expert en balistique à la retraite
le principe c'est d'avoir un projet qu
tekki choix h épluchant pour clouer au
sol un adversaire un agresseur mais qui
n'engendre pas de traumatisme permanent
voir un cas mortel le flash ball est ce
qu'on appelle un lanceur de balles de
défense
le gign a d'abord tester ce modèle les
polices étrangères on entend ensuite
commandé puis en 1995 c'est la brigade
anticriminalité qui s'est équipé de
flash ball c'est une quête incessante de
la part des fonctionnaires qui vont
l'utiliser nos informations entre est
très soutenu et surtout permanente afin
que cette arme ne pose aucun problème
d'autant que les consignes de la
direction de la police sont claires visé
sous les épaules et à une distance d'au
moins sept mètres cherchait du travail
propre à jeudi reste un travail propre
en plus on l'a pas tué on peut le projet
des questions du travail propre
une illusion le flash-ball débarque dans
les manifestations dès 1995 et pose
problème dans les années 2000 larmes et
pas très précise et les consignes de
sécurité ne sont pas toujours respectées
par les agents résultat des dizaines de
personnes grièvement blessées certaines
ont même perdu l'usagé d'un oeil
comme cet étudiant à toulouse en 2009 on
s'est retrouvé à dix quinze vingt mètres
je ne sais pas exactement
là on m'a tiré dessus plus grave à
marseille en 2011
un homme est mort après un arrêt
cardiaque consécutif à un tir de
flashball
même s'il est toujours utiliser le
flash-ball à petit à petit été remplacé
à partir de 2009 par le lbd40 même type
d'armes plus précis avec une portée de
40 mètres mais surtout bien plus
douloureux lbd40 ou flash ball
l'utilisation de lanceurs de balles de
défense fait débat début 2018
le défenseur des droits proposé à
l'assemblée nationale de les interdire
dans le cadre du maintien de l'ordre
[Musique]
oh